un gouvernement de la CAQ va mettre en
place pour faire un appel d'offres pour
200 médicaux privés le gouvernement logo
passe aux actes et lance deux projets de
mini hôpitaux privés un Montréal qui
prioriserait les soins aux années
l'autre Québec orienté surtout vers la
pédiatrie deux établissements construits
et gérés par le privé ou les soins
seraient payés par l'État d'avoir un
partenaire privé mais qui collabore avec
le public pour donner des soins qui sont
gratuits qui sont universels mais qui
vont pouvoir par exemple décharger les
urgences qui vont pouvoir faire baisser
des attentes en chirurgie depuis la
pandémie les cliniques privées réalisent
maintenant plus de 10% des chirurgies
payées par Québec certaines se montrent
déjà intéressés à gérer ses petits
hôpitaux privés ont réussi je crois en
faire un peu plus avec un peu moins en
terme d'utilisation des ressources les
hôpitaux privés vont contribuer un peu à
ce schéma essayer de remettre présenter
le système de santé sur ses rails
travailler en collaboration pendant
complémentarité avec le réseau public
puis d'offrir des conditions de
rémunération des conditions de travail
qui sont comparables au réseau public
pour éviter des déplacements de
main-d'oeuvre c'est encore et toujours
le gros défi évitez un exode de la main
d'oeuvre du public vers le privé si les
conditions de travail devait y être
meilleur fait que si on a compétiteur
qui a 20 pièces de plus de valeur c'est
sûr que là ils vont nous manger tout
rond Québec souhaite rapidement passer
aux appels d'offres et compléter la
construction des deux mini hôpitaux
d'ici 2025 et le gouvernement affirme
que la construction de ce petit hôpital
privé d'ici 2025 ne retardera pas la
reconstruction du gros hôpital public de
Maisonneuve-Rosemont qui doit se faire
d'ici 2030 ici David Gentile
Radio-Canada Montréal